let me ask another big philosophical
question
um
what's human what makes us human what is
human and
where did that humanness come from
that's exactly the question we need to
problematize because it's what i call
the gandhi question it's like
uh you know gandhi's asked what do you
think of western civilization and he
says it would be a good idea
you know and so when did humans evolve
you know well
not yet
so
we don't talk about you know when did
you know
we talk about the rise of modern
humanity
and what's happened in the last
50 or 60 years or so which i think is a
good thing intellectually is that we've
smeared out humanness
to mean many different things it's not
just tool use
it's not just upright posture upright
posture goes back at least five million
years
tool use goes back at least two and a
half million years stone two years but
since wasps and chimpanzees use tools
then it's got to be even older
so that that's actually one of the
things i'm interested is
how have different notions
of what is human
influence our theories of
human origins
and
in particular there's sort of the
problem of what i call like sodomy in
the uncanny valley which is
how long ago would you be willing to
date someone say
someone that existed say 5 million years
ago 10 million years ago 3 million years
ago in other words when is it like date
or one night stands i mean that's wrong
okay
let's say be the the the mother of your
children
um that's a lot of commitment but yeah
but it's an interesting question because
after world war ii
as a result of
nazism
no one wanted to be the one to say that
this particular fossil we've just found
was anything less than fully human so
there's a projection of humanness
arbitrarily back
into the past
so that even these little monkey-like
creatures ramapithe scenes
rhombopithicus were being declared to
have folkways and mores and language
which is ridiculous
no one want to be one to say that
neanderthals were anything less than
fully human so it's a very interesting
question
at what point are they us i mean human
origins is very much an identity quest
it's when did we become us
which sort of begs the question what are
we who are we
um and how much is that is the hardware
evolution question and versus the
software like what
the actual development of society like
can't you argue that we became human
with uh with agriculture
i mean can't you argue that we became
human with the industrial revolution
well certainly by then
they are us
but
agriculture is only 12 000 years ago
that's a blink in the eye right that's
that's yesterday
it's interesting prior to the 19th
century
most scholars thought that the pyramids
were at the beginning of time
essentially they were closer to the
beginning of time than they are to us
now
it's a blink in the eye you know we use
the metaphor of a meter you know the
earth is 5 billion
so that's a meter
the natural history of upright humans is
five million so that's
that would be like one millimeter this
would be the thickness of the white
of your fingernail
and then the pyramids are 5 000 so
that's a thousandth
of a millimeter a micron which is the
amount taken off
when you brush your
fingers on your
your jacket
so the there's a natural history of
humanity and then there's the history of
our constituents we're all stardust
because all of our complex atoms began
in
supernovas
many billions of years ago
but
upright posture 5 million
agriculture only a few thousand
years ago
we cultivate dogs a couple hundred
thousand years ago so those are
paleolithic instruments cats are
neolithic instruments because they're
used to kill vermin dogs are used to
to hunt with us
but there is what you say this
co-evolution our social aspect yeah and
our physical aspect even the fact that
we have whites of the eyes we're the
only animal with whites of the eyes
and the whites of the eyes
tell intent
they tell direction they tell interest
they know
if you look at something i can tell what
you're looking at because there's a
lateral
resolution i can tell what you're
looking at
that's recent
and
the people who do reconstruction for
museums they want to create what i call
an ethnographic identity with the viewer
and so they
fantasize about all these other early
hominids non-human pre-human hominids if
that's a word
as having eyes like us but they probably
didn't
and they were probably
not self-aware
at least the early ones i can't have
been self-aware the way we are insofar
as we are
they may not have spoke
so i'm
interested in
basically when did we become what we
think is human it's clear that when we
start
burying the dead and making jewel making
jewelry and and
when we in a sense invent fantasy
when we invent deception
that's human that's fully human we
become human
by
thinking there's a world that really is
not
i mean that's that feels like we start
to operate in the space of ideas more
and more so to to have deception to have
imagination
you start to be able to have ideas and
share them and it feels like the sharing
is the thing that really develops the
idea so it's not you come up with ideas
and you we become able to sort of
understand what each other is thinking
some animals can do this to a certain
extent dogs have a certain empathy but
it's it's limited it's highly limited
but you could probably argue that the
dogs got that from the humans yeah i
mean humans and dogs have co-evolved
have definitely co-evolved because it's
over a hundred thousand years we've been
working together there
but but all our hands have evolved with
tools
and so i'm trying to figure out now the
original purpose is the purpose of the
julian hand axes the old the first
beautiful tool made by humans which
were made unchanged what kind of axe is
this they're called the shulian hand
axes they're the these beautiful
teardrop shaped
objects that go back 1.5 million years
and what's your thought about his
possible purposes
well the
most important thing to murder is that a
jealous husband comes home what's
astonishing is that no one knows what
they were used for
so they may have been
maps they may have been weapons they may
have been chopping devices
they may have been sexual displays
oh
like ornaments to to display something
versus actual
like the peacock's tail
you